in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to an episode of the
genius brain podcast we have the fro
master mm a ka light skin aka Vietnamese
black man we have Khalif Boyd in the
house aka the original Dom Benjamin Don
Benjamin I heard he is not with the lady
what's her name
I haven't seen them in a video together
in a while I shall be spreading rumors
about everybody LeeAnn yeah they were
the ultimate the ultimat couple yeah the
light-skinned Filipino with the lights
yeah man what you've been doing uh you
know I've been I'm still birding I'm
putting good used to my binoculars that
I bought dude at 7-eleven it was a very
awkward other than that I repolish my
weights yeah you said that you went to
Huntington Beach right and no bro man so
I want to where I go Costa Mesa to get
some sidecar doughnuts no I'm not you
know I don't really do desserts and
sweets and doughnuts and all that stuff
but for some reason I want a sidecar
doughnuts so I told my dog come on girl
let's go PCH and get these doughnuts so
I Drive they get doughnuts and on my way
back I'm driving by Huntington Beach and
I kid you not there was like on every
block every corner there was like at
least a dozen people with no mask no
social distancing just eating together
and then as I'm going to each
intersection people just like by the
groves just like crossing the street no
practicing of you know protection and
then safety so yeah they will give a
[ __ ] down there I forgot why I heard
this from but it was a buddy of mine
he's in Texas not sure where he read
this but he told me that you know they
they forgot what part of Texas well I'm
not sure if it's all of Texas but
they're they're done with the whole
social distancing thing and they opened
up restaurants or whatever and it was
like in the weekend that it was like
that like there was like 18,000 new
cases of crazy yeah it's crazy about
dads like I always look because I I try
not to pay too much attention
- when it's on TV but I'm always curious
about the numbers of LA versus OC yeah
and LA has a crazy number and OC is more
of the you see on television showing
that they don't care and oh yeah masks
and they have lower numbers maybe
there's some statistical reason for that
well it's definitely like population and
stuff it's definitely population right
cuz the OC is a lot more spread out cuz
you think it's right
Irvine mmm nobody lives next to each
other line everything is like a couple
of miles away from each other versus
like we're talking about the heart of
DTLA Little Tokyo there's a population
per like square whatever square mile in
France it's really elite Daily's really
really - all right cuz even those see
it's like Costa Mesa Tustin and I'm like
it's very yeah I mean 4hp
like I'm on that weird scale of trying
to figure out what's the good medium for
social because it can't be like this
forever there hasn't been this this sign
that it's going to its it hasn't been as
bad as what the statistics have said to
be right they said that half a
californium was going to get infected
and all this other stuff and some people
are saying well it's because we have
been social distancing right which it
could be true but the stats are so weird
I don't know what to believe anymore one
day I'm worried and the next day I'm
just like [ __ ] it and that [ __ ]
completely but just like okay maybe I
won't be freaked out as much and then
you know if some people make comparisons
to Sweden they're like well in Sweden
they have the same population as la they
don't social distance and look at them
I'm like yeah but you're you're you're
comparing the size of Sweden to the
square of square miles of how big la is
I'm not a coal country versus the city
yeah so we're a lot more population
dense than Sweden of course so that's a
huge factor as well I think when people
want to leave and they want don't want
to be confined they're trying to find
the reason any reason to get out we're
just trying to find a reason for
termination right for sure like I I'm I
don't know like even for me like I'm not
wearing my mask as much right cuz before
it was everywhere where that I was
walking or whatever then I read this
article that if you're exercising don't
wear a mask assumes worse you're
breathing some okay well what the [ __ ]
now yeah so what am i doing I think is
yeah so even going down you know back
down and I'll stop doing my runs mm-hm
I remember seeing a woman on the street
one woman's like you know I could tell
she was entitled to it for me to step
off
and another woman she's elder I could
tell she was like just there must have
been a senior home across you know or a
nearby and I write I want on the street
walked ran past her and she's like
excuse me excuse me I'm like okay and I
turn around she's like thank you you
didn't have to do that but thank you oh
[ __ ] man so like it makes me feel good
that she feels like I care about my
neighbor yeah her that makes me feel a
responsibility to that something like
[ __ ] well you know I still don't know
why people still [ __ ] wear masks
while driving with the windows up oh
that's a little weird I mean I I I guess
what some somebody said it was because
it's too exhausting to take it on and
off when they're going to the grocery
store so I guess I don't know where
you're going so I just leave it to like
that but that mask is uncomfortable I
mean if you got Corona in your car you
got Corona in your car hold me that's
about it son are you killing all your
family members no you're pretty much
done at that point if it's in your car I
mean to put it in perspective I guess
this is the part that resonates with me
they go okay well how does it make sense
right that you can't find a medium for
people those social distance in public
parks or whatever but we're allowed to
go into supermarkets elbow-to-elbow with
somebody basically right because you put
these markers on the floor saying that
you have to be six feet away I am you
never six feet away it's impossible
there's ISA there's these scientists say
you can only go this way
there's no way there's some every time
I've been in an aisle and I follow those
rules I go through traffic is this way
there's always ten people going this way
and I'm like it does what is this hmm
you know so I mean in those cases yeah I
wear a mask anytime you go into a
supermarket Nellie you have to wear a
mask it's been a while since I've been
in a supermarket under those guidelines
and safety measures that and these these
stores are doing but I also do notice
that a lot more stores are having lines
outside the store so I don't know what I
don't know what that traffic looks like
when they're like slowly funneling
people into the store to that create the
overcrowding I mean because of
restaurants I think Sacramento is
starting to reopen right now
in very constricted ways of opening up
so what I mean by that is for example
like if you're in a restaurant you're
each table has to be a certain amount of
feet away from each other and there and
they can lonely and they're limiting the
amount of people that can dine within
the restaurant which makes sense right
so but it at least gives them something
to look forward to because a lot of
these businesses are shutting down
for example no more soup plantation
people upset they're like no more soup
plantation I go when's the last time you
went there like seven years too many
years well I was Souplantation to have
such a Gravatar your high school was
popping for us everybody you know what
is that why look it was the focaccia
pizza bread it was the chicken noodle
soup the clam chowder the fries that
all-you-can-eat soft surf so yeah okay
so Hometown Buffet or Souplantation wait
a super mentation ie all-you-can-eat so
Souplantation I think it hit hit the
right wave of when everybody was trying
to get healthy that's when that whole
healthy [ __ ] started happening and
everybody wanted to be a part of that
they were like okay well if I'm gonna be
healthy look at this place it's all
vegetables but lo and behold people
weren't even getting the fresh veggies
they were getting the broccoli cells
which was mayonnaise and vinegar with
apple cider and brown sugar and then
bacon bits and they were getting the
macaroni salad which is pasta and
mayonnaise and then they would go to the
clam chowder and then they would get
focaccia pizza bread and eat it with
that and they thought that they were
making healthy choices that literally
was me I thought that I was making
healthy choices and I left that every
[ __ ] time no way I don't blame you
because Souplantation was one was place
to be known to like help you like subway
was like like yeah I was in that
category that foot long in that veggie
sub whatever even just getting Italian
sub for some reason subway really did a
good job but you can be subway tricked
the [ __ ] out of me man all the time and
I wasn't losing no [ __ ] yeah exactly but
then I used to switch it up in my own
can you scoop out that bread on the
inside yeah
as I and I get some light mail with that
and either way that [ __ ] was still like
800 calories and I went down two of them
because I didn't know what my caloric
intake I didn't know what that [ __ ] is
so you thought about that break for more
mayonnaise yeah I scooped out the bread
and now I want you squeeze mayonnaise in
the cavity I and then at the death
I want you add olives don't you get put
a [ __ ] vegetable and then double up
to me and there's like excuse me walk
out I'm like I just made a good choice
yeah yeah yeah music good but Dan you
still only eat that one sandwich and
then not eat anything for the rest of
the day he has some really unhealthy
food habits like he would go up and down
and wait all the [ __ ] time
was it did you ever do a tuna melt with
hot cheetos not you that wasn't me at
all I don't I don't like tuna melts it's
not that I don't like tuna melts is just
that uh I feel like every time I got one
it tasted like the tin like subway I I
got the stuff that I knew exactly what I
wanted stuff that I wanted was it was a
turkey avocado and I got it with the
whole wheat bread cuz that's hella
healthier right the bread light Mayo I
would get spinach no [ __ ] lettuce
pallav the peppers tomatoes olive oil
red vinegar salt and pepper and that was
my healthy one right and then if I
wanted to be even healthier than that I
got the the ham actually had less
calories than the turkey did you see the
people were like up in arms about
musician was really big lost a lot of
weight European British oh no Adele like
she's [ __ ] more shed more CISOs by the
seashore she my saying right now she
shed more weight than she had before cuz
I'm her she oh she had like a little
stint where she lost
last was more weight yeah she lost in
absorbing amount away I wasn't kind of
shocked there was a photo of her where
she was just you know standing next to
somebody and she looked a little worn
out and I think that was the photo that
everybody was talking about and they
were gossiping about how she lost weight
in a very unhealthy way without even
asking her without even getting a
statement about it yeah man I love to
bill you up you did it's weird because
I've been you know when I'm on Twitter
and stuff and I'm listening
you could tell what's trending by how
much things pop up there are a few
people that I follow and they're fans of
mine right I follow them not because we
have a connection I follow them because
they are the most basic human beings on
earth and they follow the most basic
tweets so they're the people that keep
me connected I don't know [ __ ] about
what's going on so when when I know when
they retweet [ __ ] that's what everybody
else don't have to know yeah so I'm like
okay this is the thing right and so
these about it's like 10 or 15 people
when they all in consensus start
tweeting the same [ __ ] and they have an
opinion about it I must step down I'm
like this is this is what's poppin and
so all of them had a tweet about Adele's
weight loss and some of it was
interesting because that conversation is
going it's number one okay there's
there's this whole hot topic right now
it's about fat phobia mmm right I had no
idea what fat phobia is right it's like
I was like is that a fear of being fat
but what they're talking about is people
people who are fat phobic or people who
look down on people who are fat or some
[ __ ] like oh yeah it's like the whole
fat phobia thing I mean you guys can
write the actual definition of it I
don't really give a [ __ ] this podcast is
brought to you by Skillshare my friends
Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of aspiring
classes for creative and curious people
explore new skills deep in existing
passions and get lost in creativity
they've got classes for productivity
lifestyle creative writing film and a
whole bunch more Skillshare offers
creative classes designed for real life
and all the circumstances that comes
with it it's always the right time to
stay inspired express yourself and
connect with the community of millions
right now I'm checking out this course
called every day minimalism my friends I
don't like clutter
I don't like junk and I'm trying to stay
as minimal as possible because I'm
starting to realize
that a clean space is a happy space
Skillshare had something on their
courses that help me out with this and I
would have never thought they would but
they do and it's dope explore your
creativity and get two free months of
premium membership at Skillshare comm
slash brain that's two whole months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for free get started and joined today by
heading to Skillshare comm slash brain
the best to three months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes at
Skillshare dot-com slash brain but
there's two sides right it's if you're
if you celebrate your health you're not
so much your health if you celebrate
your weight loss if you celebrate how
much you became fit from how you were
before if you're talking about how you
feel great about you know showing your
six-pack abs you're actually a catalyst
to this negative conversation about
people who are who are overweight and so
you're a very fat phobic person and
you're a very bad person right and
there's the other side where it's like
if you are extremely overweight and
you're unhealthy you keep finding
reasons to feel better about yourself
even though you know you're unhealthy
and you're just finding things and
finding information to support your bad
habits and you want other people to feel
bad just like you do kind of like oh
it's a cartoon about Liz oh and Cheryl I
mean a guy was talking about that Liz oh
just like when she shook her when she
shook her ass at the Staples game Emory
was like oh my god can you do that yeah
you're overweight and like you're
talking about not you know it's not
about fat shaming but I love my body and
I'm healthy and goes back to my friends
like friends trying to lose weight
during this quarantine especially
because I have no excuse to that you
know they're trying to you know if I
don't if if but if if every person that
likes this gets like ten bucks if I
don't meet my goal mmm and it's been
interesting watching her friends being
like sure update us like it's been a
really difficult I didn't lose anyway
and person is like you don't have to
lose weight you look beautiful and like
she's kind of beasts yeah she's obese
since kind of like her friend it's in a
weird place with this yeah I mean
because I'm trying to figure out what
it's like right because
I was extremely big I'm still on the
fluffier side right now maybe people
might disagree they're like no your skit
your your skimpy I still like for me I'm
about I float around like 207 to like
212 pounds that's that's where i
fluctuate constantly right and people
know how big I was I was about 270
almost 280 and I dropped that weight so
somebody is caught talking to me right
and they go you know what dude they're
like you were fine the way you were
before that's cool right I'm glad that
you thought I was fine I I didn't I
didn't lose weight because I thought it
was [ __ ] ugly you [ __ ]
I do you look so good before to [ __ ] you
right now [ __ ] on me I'm like you
thought it was ugly
the whole time bro you were handsome I
never said I was ugly whoo why do you
keep saying this and so when I lost
weight it was it was because I knew I
couldn't do the things that I wanted to
do period end of story I couldn't play
ball the way I wanted to I got my knees
were hurting and I think what happens to
and you know people can disagree with
this if you're bigger or whatnot this is
coming from a guy who's still big and is
still trying to you know drop in my last
20 or so pounds so I could feel better
and make me healthier life choices when
you're that big every day pain to you
starts to become numb because it's just
a normal part of your life I know
there's a lot of big people right now
that might disagree but I know there's a
[ __ ] fat chunk of you no pun intended
that you you know what that's like cuz I
know exactly what that's like I know
what it's like to normalize your pain I
know what it's like to normalize acid
reflux because I was eating terrible
food I know what it's like to normalize
my knee pain when I would go on simple
blocks I know it wasn't like to
normalize I wanted to Park closer to a
supermarket because I know how my fat
ass didn't want to walk that extra
distance right so these type of things
is the reason why I'm a little bit
conflicted on understanding why right
and I do get the the people who are
talking about fat phobia and in the
forms of you know you don't need the
six-pack I don't I don't think anybody
needs a [ __ ] six-pack I'm sorry like
if you have it and that's your
hobby and goal I think that's [ __ ]
dope you don't need that I think you
need to make healthy life choices and
then you need to in order to feel better
right because there's a lot of like
everyday pain stuff that you're dealing
with because you are extremely
overweight that you know that's there
but you choose to ignore it because it's
hard it's hard to lose weight it's hard
to make smart choices when you want to
be healthy I [ __ ] know but then when
you look at food in a way that you
realize that it's an addiction that's
when your perspective starts to change
because it is an addiction it's weird
that what if I tell myself right when
I'm eating this food like for example
one of my biggest vices is instant ramen
I [ __ ] love that [ __ ] during this
quarantine I've probably eaten about
three boxes of instant ramen to myself I
love that [ __ ] but we were walking every
[ __ ] day every time I ate one of that
[ __ ] I know that okay number one I just
inhaled a bunch of sodium so I need to
sweat the [ __ ] out cuz I have a high
blood protect propensity for high blood
pressure so you know we went on these
daily walks I know the balance in
between right but the problem with some
people now especially when it comes to
weight loss they're confusing some
things they're confusing that
confirmation bias that they have so for
example what I mean by that confirmation
bias there I keep reading this
conversation over and over in the
comments they go just because I'm fat it
doesn't mean that I'm not fit unless
you're an athlete like a linebacker
you're a power lifter or whatever
whatnot and you haven't done a study on
your body like a physical study on your
body you have no right to say that
because a typical marker for somebody
being unhealthy when they are overweight
which leads to other stuff like like
hypertension high blood pressure high
cholesterol all that other stuff and the
food that you eat there's a reason for
that right there is it are there people
who are supposed to be a little more
heavyset because genetically it's like
that yeah for sure a hundred percent and
I used to tell my [ __ ] myself that [ __ ]
all the time I was like I'm big-boned
I got regular bones I'm just really fat
that's all that it was so we want to do
this confirmation buzz because we want
to we want to believe sometimes the
stuff that we know that we should change
because we don't want to because it's
hard we keep trying to find reasons why
we shouldn't
hmm I know because I was like that as
well
so when you have this conversation in
somebody and we start mixing societal
standards of what beauty is versus
scientific fact of your health that's
when there's this is weird confusion
starts to happen they go I keep reading
this comment just to go back to what I
was saying of you are not fat it's not
you're not fat it's just because I'm fat
it doesn't mean that I'm out of shape
it's like okay what do you mean they go
there are people out there who are who
are larger who are way healthier than
these skinnier people who are thin and
out of shape
cool we're not talking about that and we
know you know what that's called it's
called what about isms mmm right it's
going somebody says something to you
that's the fact that might hurt you you
go okay but what about this yeah you're
never addressing what somebody saying to
you they go okay if you are on this
morbidly obese scale which some people
have a an issue with the with that title
morbidly obese so I'm just saying that
because that's like the scientific you
know health term right if you are
morbidly obese right and then your
reason is that I know some people who
are obese or actually really healthy and
they're very active cool is that you
probably not is that because on Trump
it's like is that you and most people
who say that and you guys can agree with
this too
probably aren't that people because I'm
still technically obese I could say that
I could say hey I'm obese but I kickbox
right I walk eight [ __ ] miles a day I
do eat what I want so I'm pretty much
okay with it I got my blood checked all
my triglycerides all of the stuff it's
on [ __ ] point so when somebody says
you're unhealthy to me I'm like cool
let's get into this [ __ ] gym right
now and you try to [ __ ] me up in this
kickboxing match for five [ __ ]
minutes let's see what happens yeah I
can say that how about a bio hawk 211
mile walk and then let's see what we
brought about three four people's feet
fell off yeah all right
they thought they were in 12 years a
slave like every time I turn around
there's a straw hat on yeah I turned
around again his mother got chained on
his I can say that because I'm on the
I'm on the technically obese scale but I
can show you the activity that I've done
right having said that I feel like most
people who talk about that stat or that
statistic aren't in that range hmm right
yeah
they're not there in the morbidly obese
range that they sit they eat terrible
foods they have poor life choices and
they want to fit into that category and
then on the other side they go these
skinny people doesn't mean that they're
necessarily healthy - you are a hundred
percent right just because you're thin I
know a lot of people who are thin and if
I took an image of their insides it's
probably filled with dirt rocks and hi
so I do get it right but when we're
talking about an indicator of health
when you are I wouldn't say thin I would
say average weight right I'm not talking
about skinny with the six-pack if your
average weight and you look at somebody
who was more on the obese side you would
tend to think that the person who was
thinner is a little more healthy if you
waited out statistically the person who
was the average weight for their height
and age they're probably a lot more
healthy than the person that's 50 to 60
pounds heavier right so that's the part
where I have an issue with saying that
random thing to make you feel better
because you because you know society
tends to favor people who are a little
more thin and fit doesn't change the
fact that you're unhealthy it doesn't it
didn't change the fact that I wasn't
healthy
I was still unhealthy I just chose to
change my perspective about food and now
that I lost about like 60 pounds if I
want to lose that extra 30 and get
jacked I know the work that it takes and
I know that it's [ __ ] hard do I
really want it if kind of but not really
I want it was just so I could do it as a
goal right but after that I'm not
planning to keep it around you know and
then I think - just to kind of wrap this
thought up it's people who are bigger
like me I think the bigger issue is and
the reason why people have a problem
with it is why do you have to go out of
your way to tell me that I'm fat I think
that's what they want to say mmm all the
other statistics about hey a big person
can be fit to this person here that just
because you're skinny it doesn't mean
that you're unfit what you're really
trying to say is why do you have to go
out of your way to tell me that I'm fat
and make me feel bad about something
that I already know that's the truth I
surely believe that this is coming from
a fat person hmm but you're trying to
battle it with this with this
pseudoscience
right right so just be upfront about it
say hey I know I'm big thank you for
your concern
but I don't really care so don't worry
about it
wait this thought happens to you person
not me I'm talking about other people
people don't really see make those
comments I'm I lost a lot of weight
right right but if somebody goes out
their way I think what the real problem
is is why do you [ __ ] care so much
that I'm fat mind your [ __ ] business
and because it's funny now or it has
been for a long time to make some make
fun of somebody because they're fat
which I don't understand why that's even
an insult to look at somebody go you're
[ __ ] fat it's funny because we grew
up with it right but if you kind of step
back and you look at it it's like why is
that even an insult in the first place
why is it that your observation of this
person's obesity a humorous thing right
you know look at this fat [ __ ] right you
know this dude spice Adams put that
thing up on Instagram recently which is
spicy you know surprise ha ha ha there's
one clip that made me [ __ ] die
laughing right so spicy Adams has his
clip where he's eating food he goes
every time a fat person is eating this
is what [ __ ] had to say so this
was eating a salad like damn this
[ __ ] going down on that [ __ ]
he's like just a salad I'm just eating
his like [ __ ] being hungry huh
chomp down on that [ __ ] I want you
breathe a little social commentary about
somebody's weight and I think that that
kind of [ __ ] with some people's
mentality it [ __ ] with their
self-esteem yeah cuz visually it's so
easy to attack like oh you're bigger
than normal
exactly there's wrong with you yeah like
the fat jokes the easiest thing right
I've had fat joe said to me so much I
gotta rolodexes of that [ __ ] so I could
make fun of another fatter person than
me like nothing being a debt has a
folder folders of jokes all day he had a
folder they said ethnic jokes no I want
to read that [ __ ] so bad Clifford J
Clifford J Boyd F me live at the Long
Beach aquarium 2022 and since I was 16 I
have never ever had a folder that said
ethnic jokes
in my life hey that's why I want to read
that joke dad's like stand up said he
goes so you know these [ __ ] gooks
yeah but people had that crazy opinion
about weight loss and I think it's more
of an emotional thing I think it's not
so much that you want to defend the fact
that being bigger is scientifically
proven to be better or that it's it's
okay to be healthy I think you're
finding those facts to kind of really
just say back the [ __ ] off me I stop
making fun of me because I'm bigger or
something that I'm dealing with yeah
yeah I don't know where that entitlement
comes from for people actually I know
where it comes from from people reading
these articles thinking like oh this
doctor says this I understand an article
- what they think they do
and then regurgitate and put on put on
other people because they're probably
reading that for their own
I don't know education because there's
so many information coming about like
health and what it looks like and what
you should be doing exercise wise and
diet why's that you're the person
themselves are wrestling with trying to
figure out what's healthy how does that
feel am i doing the things am i rising
before the Sun and this and they're
reading these encouraging aspire
inspirational stories and then like you
said like fat people are just so easy to
attack and I don't know why that matters
to that person other than I'm just
looking out for you I just want to make
sure you know beats and high cholesterol
this isn't that yeah why do you have to
go out of your way to say it like that
I don't know cuz what what if someone
was like hey check out this article and
then you read it and it's about like fat
loss or some like I would die laughing
but I'm a little different dog like man
[ __ ] you dog if I was like in the middle
of the night and then my brother he's a
nurse and he just sends his over he goes
dude Asian males with larger breasts
have a 5% chance of having breast cancer
I would be like that's [ __ ] first of
all that's [ __ ] I think it's funny and
I don't know about [ __ ] you dude how
dare you send this [ __ ] to me thank you
for being concerned but this is not the
way to do it yeah and my breasts aren't
that big yeah I'll quit the soy yeah
let's just talk about this in general -
there's a reason
I they were talking about quote like
comorbidity with Corona that people who
were on the ob side we're going to
struggle with fighting off the virus
right there is a health issue with being
overweight yeah there is it's hard to
argue with the facts and the science
behind that right it's hard for somebody
to argue to me that that we I think in
first world countries we have a very
unhealthy relationship with food right
but then I also do agree with people
when they say the the concept of what
beauty standards are really [ __ ] [ __ ] up
people's mentality a lot right like you
like the whole summer body mentality
right like you have to look this way
before you go out to the beach right so
I think it's dumb it all starts in your
head you could ask anybody that [ __ ]
with me men understood me whenever I
went to a beach my shirt was off whether
I was fat or not maybe because I didn't
know I was that fat but I didn't I
didn't give a [ __ ] like me i'm at the
beach i'm i'm gonna go into the water do
baby I'm taking off my [ __ ] shirt I
always found it weird when I saw a
bigger person big just like me at the
time they would keep their shirt on they
go into the water playing time yeah I'm
like yo you fat [ __ ] ha ha you know I
mean we're fat just cuz you have a shirt
on it doesn't mean go rest of the beach
or whoever's looking at you doesn't know
you're [ __ ] fat take off your [ __ ]
shirt [ __ ] all these people just be
comfortable right and it would make me
feel so bad sometimes when I see fat
people wear their shirts cuz I would be
the fat person in the water just with my
shirt off it's like that t-shirt by the
way isn't your Harry Potter invisibility
cloak a [ __ ] they see you
especially one though when the shirt
gets wet and it drapes over them titties
they know what stuff that should look
like a Cindy Margolis wet t-shirt you
know I mean you making people a little
horny I never understood that sure I
will never understand that right and
though and sometimes with those people
too they go back they go I don't I like
being fat then once you take off your
shirt then if you're so proud of that
[ __ ] be real with yourself if you don't
want to be fat that's cool if you want
to stay fat that's cool too but be
honest with yourself just above our
heads just like it like that the
information is so fluctuating especially
you know Instagram yeah I want to go for
this body and then
you see the other buddy that's kind of
slightly different in that body but that
body has like 20,000 more likes I'm like
you look so hot and this and that as
like [ __ ] I want that body and then you
scroll Scroll scroll see that body and
like oh [ __ ] which health plan do I go
to and like and then just like oh now
like Lizza was like oh I love lizzle
number one
Time magazine Person of the Year blah
blah like okay I could just beat myself
and now she's being attacked and like
people are like okay you can't be fine
Lizza because now people are not riding
with her so why aren't you losing weight
yeah so people just just like all these
attacks I mean the movie when she was
shaking her ass at Lakers was more like
some children it was there that was kind
of crazy ass you happened in front of
these [ __ ] five girls even before
that all right given that stable thing
was kind of crazy it was crazy but
before that she was being fat shamed
yeah for sure cuz they mean alter it
like that when she really blew up and
then no pun intended
yeah yeah I mean and I guess I get me
were just to think off the cuff uh I
want to say like it's even more of an
like an animal instinct for people to
want to be with people who are fit
because they live longer yeah you know
they were attracted to things just on an
animalistic sense is from a primal sense
that they want to be with healthier
people and they find that a lot more
attractive I think that's a primal thing
that people want you know I think humans
on the other hand we have this huge
brain of ours we have all this empathy
we have all this emotion we're highly
intelligent so we can work past that we
don't need to look at somebody and say
oh this person's gonna bear the fruit of
my you know for the for X amount of
years and generation we can think beyond
that so we have we had that ability to
judge somebody's like beauty and
character aside from what they can
revive with their ovaries and their
[ __ ] semen in their [ __ ] balls you
know so that's it's just a really weird
space to be in men like I because people
are asking me to you know weigh my
opinion on Adele losing weight and my
opinion is I don't give a [ __ ] I could
give a [ __ ] less what Adele did with her
[ __ ] way dude why do you care exactly
if she's happy with it and then kudos to
her she lost weight because I don't know
she was depressed out of her mind she
should get [ __ ] help right
why do I [ __ ] care I don't [ __ ]
care dude I could give a [ __ ] less what
[ __ ] Adele does I don't care what
woman who's rich beyond her [ __ ]
balloon makes amazing music I care about
her music that's what I want to know I
don't know what kind of [ __ ] album
you're gonna drop after you got done by
your [ __ ] husband I don't want to see
ya you know but so when you asked me
about my opinion about Adele's weight
loss who the [ __ ] cares I was shocked I
was a goddamn she looks like she looked
like a deflated balloon I [ __ ]
let the air out very you know yeah very
pretty I thought she was pretty much she
was big faces [ __ ] pretty as hell but
if you're asking my opinion about what
her weight loss is I don't [ __ ] care
dude it's cool like I'm if she's happy
that she feels healthier I'm happy that
she's healthy other than that I don't
give up look I don't give a [ __ ] if you
give that much of a crap about Adele's
weight loss you are loser you're a big
loser man yeah and you're sitting here
you're gossiping about Oh what does she
do it healthfully or not I don't know
who the [ __ ] your best friend are you
gonna call her up like Adele how you do
that way lost you know yeah [ __ ] works
yeah tell me what how you do that [ __ ]
you starving hey what [ __ ] you ain't
best friends with her live her [ __ ]
life if she want to talk about it then
that's fine but a lot of people a lot of
these celebrities they have a lot of
power and so they're kind of worried
about public perception and these the
the youth and how they're gonna perceive
that there's a lot of there's a lot more
terrible things that celebrities are
doing other than a Dell losing weight
mmm like stop tripping right I'm saying
yeah I mean yeah totally cuz we do I
mean from the time that we CEO saw down
which is big and where she lost weight
we had no idea what she was doing
exactly she's like maybe she was working
out who knows who the [ __ ] knows yeah
unless her friends are like saying oh
struggling with drug addiction or
something like that but that's not the
case I mean like she's just living her
life
that's what it looks like to me she
looks perfectly fine man I've never I
don't know man I I always it's weird
like though the whole weight loss
concept just I know how difficult it is
and I know how
I don't want to compare myself to like
most people because I saw most of my
self-esteem or personal issues with
humor so that was that was the way I
dealt with it so I don't want to make a
false comparison to other people because
not a lot of people can deal with their
insecurities the way that I did I'm not
saying that I wasn't affected by it
right when I was younger and you know my
nickname was fat so for a little bit
yeah I mean I should used to piss me off
but then I got smarter and I just made
fun of them even harder than they made
fun of me and then I the playing field
was a little even so I kind of like
dealt with my my [ __ ] that way but one
thing I didn't deny was the fact that
how terrible I felt this fool knows I
hate [ __ ] Avenue 26 tacos every
[ __ ] night yeah man your big dude six
Paco's too it was always six minimum
yeah and then if my brother or somebody
didn't finish their tacos you best
believe the dumpsters coming all that
shout out the ever new 2016 y'all want
to know what I ate honor on a regular
basis like if I told you in general
it would be like lunch I would eat
Causton pie right that was that was the
frequent so I would get their breakfast
plate hashbrowns two pieces of bacon two
pieces of sausage scrambled eggs and
then I would get like their avocado
toast on the side if I wasn't getting
that I would get their burger with their
garlic fries other side and a side this
is like that one meal and then later on
I'd be kind of full I wouldn't eat but
then somebody would hit me up as I go
you want to get some Chinese food then
I'll go eat some Chinese food yeah then
it's 1 a.m. because I couldn't go to
sleep at night then I would eat I don't
know like Vietnamese food or Chinese
food again and I get some late-night
tacos and that would be a whole day and
that's what usually wouldn't baby JJ
cafe people could normally feed a whole
family with the way I ate by myself and
I'd like to eating it was really really
good
I developed the palate for food that way
I just kept stuffing my face but I had
heartburn every day I had acid reflux
and I thought that she was normal like
everybody got that right I would wake up
in the middle of night and I would like
yak acid out because of the the raw
onions and the fatty foods I was eating
it normalized
I was like I was like uh I'll wake up
and I was kind of like have asked to
come out I'm like just the tacos that I
ate but and I'll just kind of deal with
it all the time and it got to the point
where I was hurting and I'm like this
isn't right I looked it up it's like
well you're eating high you know high
fat foods and raw onions don't digest
very well so it causes acid reflux okay
that's what it is so I stopped eating
someone to having twenty six tacos and
then remember we're I forgot I was just
playing ball at that Park in Pasadena
and that one that we used to play
outdoors and then I was like cross
somebody and I bounced the ball and the
ball left and my body didn't move damn
I'm slow it's like all these small signs
I just couldn't deny it and after a
while she's like okay dude it's time for
you to lose some [ __ ] weight yeah
that was hard cuz I had a walk I used to
listen to David Goggins every [ __ ]
day for a month straight
that one podcast so if you look up on
Joe Rogan's podcast if you look up the
interview that he had with David Goggins
he's a former military Navy SEAL oh yeah
if you listen to his story I listen to
that story every day or a month straight
every time I watch whether ears kick I
was jogging kick it was almost and I did
that for about a month ish maybe even
two months and it was in between that
cus between spring ish and and summer
some when I was getting hot so even when
it was raining I remember I just walked
I walked at least a mile it didn't
matter cuz david goddess was talking
about it's just [ __ ] water you little
[ __ ] well then what the [ __ ] what you
can't walk because it's water what's
gonna happen asked you late your ass
yeah yeah and I just [ __ ] I walked in
the rain rain or shine no matter what
non-stop and I had a stop and I
researched what foods were good for you
why foods were bad for you and how it
makes you feel yeah I used to not
believe in any of that [ __ ] I know I
used to not believe I was gonna ask you
like 20 minutes ago like how do you
would you have ever imagined the way you
talk about this stuff now that you would
be like would it pass David believe that
you would be and so into this that's why
I'm time always talking about that's why
I said about confirmation bias
I just can't researching things that
allowed me to believe that how I was
living was was something that I couldn't
change right it's like oh I was likely
feeds gummy bears all the time in he has
a six pack that's the S in his life
right I'm like well that's how he is and
this is how I am so maybe I'm just born
to be fat right there's and I started
researching people who are triathlete
triathletes and they're still fat I'm
like
yeah that me yeah my triathlete if I was
a triathlete now isn't that big
then maybe I could fall into that
category but I wasn't so I kept on
trying to put myself into the position
of people that kind of fit everything
that I still want it to be without
putting in that work right so it was
like this person is still fat and they
work out every [ __ ] day but I don't
know that person I don't know what
they're talking about I'm not and I've
never tried doing what they do and I
never saw results from it so I kept
trying to figure out things the way I
wanted to do it right so for example the
first thing that I did was I just
started doing macro nutrition right now
macro nutrition was very hard for me
because I didn't look up why these foods
were affecting me in a certain way and
why macro nutrition works right and at
the different things exactly and so
those are two different you I kept on
looking for this plug-and-play type of
solution and it never worked so I just
stopped all that [ __ ] and I said you
know what let's figure out what food
does for you why the [ __ ] is it that
when I eat a bowl of pasta and noodles
and why did people why don't they say
that foods bad
beyond because some people would just
regurgitate information they'd go that
foods processed
what's processed food you know I should
bad is what leach yeah is the flour
wives bleached flour bad what's that
what's the bleaching process for it that
makes that bad you know [ __ ] because you
know bleach stuff is why people you know
why people move on you know but for me I
was like you know what you guys you have
to stop being ignorant and let's figure
out why you shouldn't eat certain foods
and why you should eat certain foods and
what is your relationship with food why
is the fact that when you can't eat this
taco you turn into Godzilla yo how could
any taco I start breaking [ __ ] I get mad
I remember one time when I was losing
weight in that first month it came down
the stairs to go what's up man you want
to go for a walk I don't wanna [ __ ]
walk with you fat ass because doc I just
came back I just wanna see if you want
to work out all day because I was you
know addicted to this food and I
couldn't have it now is having mood
swings right and then I looked at that
as a weakness I was like dude you're
weak you can't have a taco and then
suddenly you're pouting and you're mad
and you're upset it's like a sugar high
it's the same thing as a nicotine
addiction why is it the fact that you
just cuz you can't have a [ __ ] piece
of bread you freak the [ __ ] out that's
dumb
right
and so I started to find out a very very
simple simple foundation and you guys
could look this [ __ ] up too this is just
facts hopefully
but it's your body has one your body
feeds off of one type of that energy
source right so you can go into ketosis
which is keto that means your body runs
off of fat right that's your main energy
source but how our body typically is is
that we are car burners we burn sugars
right versus we're using lipid as a way
of as a source of energy right so when
you go into ketosis you whatever those
ketones allow you to use you know fat as
a way of energy don't quote me on the
[ __ ] so when you do so when you eat
stuff such as high carb high fat you are
compounding to high energy stuff
together but your body is only made to
burn one of those so what happens if you
use carbs and if you have too much that
you have an excess of carbs and then you
still have fat so that's why you have to
limit one or the other but the problem
is high carb high fat tastes [ __ ]
delicious right it tastes so [ __ ]
good and if you start weighing out your
foods that way and you go oh this is a
high carbohydrate
this is excess energy what am I gonna do
today today I'm gonna sit around and be
on a computer do I need all this energy
probably [ __ ] not mmm probably not a
good way of looking at it yeah yeah and
that's how I started looking at it I was
like I don't need this much energy
because I know I'm not gonna be moving
I'm not gonna be that active very simple
stuff right even beyond looking into
stuff like things that have high
cholesterol and all this other things
just start with that foundation first
look at your food look at your plate I
have protein fats and carbs right that's
that's the macro nutrition right and
then you start adding other stuff with
it which is the knowledge of fiber right
what does fight what does dietary fiber
do for you do for you right it reduces
whatever your insulin levels or
something like that I forgot what the
science behind that is but for example
people talk about well you can't have
too much fruits because it has too much
sugar but it has dietary fiber in it
right so it helps with yeah yeah it
helps with your insulin or whatever
whatnot or managing the sugars in your
body or something so there's that stuff
too
doing something as simple as eliminating
processed foods that you normally eat
can
soda bread helps not because those
things per se are terrible for you
because you can't have those is because
when you add that into your diet you
don't realize how much excess energy
you're adding to the stuff that you're
that you offer your everyday stuff it's
a lot of excess energy when you don't
move so what do you need this food for
right stuff like brett has a lot of
calories because it's made to be used
instantly when we use when you pee when
you see people do like highly active
workouts when you see like for example
let's use a Marshawn Lynch for a reason
a [ __ ] love skittles you know
why that muhfucka active yeah you know I
know it seems super super dumb it sounds
super super stupid what I'm saying but
there's a reason why when people go work
out they eat a lot of sugar stuff eating
sugary [ __ ] pink candy Gatorade yeah
let's use drinks it's high carb stuff
these are that boost of energy yeah
right because that's the stuff your body
uses immediately so when you start
looking at the food like that then it
makes you feel better about and then you
start to understand these choices you
make better choices that's why now I
like it today was a sin food today I ate
everything that I wanted to eat and I
felt like [ __ ] up until recently I had
to go home take a shower relax not
eating anything drink a [ __ ] ton of
water and I felt better it's not because
a fat phobia made me feel that way is
because my body told me yeah what the
[ __ ] did you just put into your system
just put in me baby yeah what the [ __ ]
is this right your body is very very
smart and when you damaged it and you
start to be having to develop a better
relationship with your body you start to
understand how these things make you
feel you'll understand that you know
this salad probably doesn't taste that
great but when you eat a whole day of
not just salad but salad clean protein
um whatever you gonna have a juice with
that [ __ ] too but you have fruits with
that stuff right you have some rice you
have whatever right but you're not
eating a burger with you know two pounds
of cheese on it and then french fries
and then you eat it that burger again
and you're not eating things in
moderation you start to feel sluggish
your brain doesn't click as well and you
start to notice these things that's what
I'm saying
pain and this these terrible things that
you go through every day when you live
it all the time it just becomes normal
all right that's it but when you start
to feel something better then you're
like then you could start telling the
difference a lot so you don't know what
light is until you have dark
you don't know what happiness until you
feel sadness that's the same thing you
don't know what a healthy body is until
you have healthy tab is healthy choices
and you have a healthy body and you
compared to something you didn't have
before right and that's just facts
mm-hmm yeah totally I mean as a reason
like I guess the beginning of the year I
had practice pretty bad eating habits
and just seeing whatever and it did
definitely contribute to like this brain
fog it just felt like I was like my
brain just feels foggy and like it
doesn't you know where I like I was like
oh [ __ ] like I have my like just listen
to my body like he's just like uh
instead of normalizing which I would
have done 10 years ago 20 years ago it's
like having that relationship with your
body and like because when I was like oh
my health kick and like eating super
healthy like I knew I just knew but then
now that I'm not working as much or
running or working out like it's
definitely shifting things in me that I
have to pay a close attention to and
make sure that I don't fall into that so
that I don't develop any kind of issues
yeah you you could tell those things
like I haven't done that walking like
because I was sending up this yeah
that's from from the week I had I had to
run dude yeah yeah I felt I've been
feeling so [ __ ] weird yeah you know a
lot I feel like like the flow yeah
energy we were walking eight miles a day
for like yeah and then I just stopped in
this past week and a half cuz I had to
get this podcast was bad yeah it's just
like you couldn't clear your head out
yeah it's it's a weird thing and then
you know Casey and Sochi and they own
this place called cost and PI they
started doing walks and they're like oh
I can see why you do this I think it
feels good cuz they're always in the
kitchen cooking them with the kids and
they're like we're just gonna walk
around the block a couple times and
they're like oh I I feel some mental
clarity it's just a small amount of
exercise blocking doesn't require [ __ ]
from you
yeah it just requires you to do
something consistently that's free free
therapy man it's it is free therapy and
when I when people asked well what's the
exercise that you did is some people
still don't [ __ ] believe I just
walked I literally just walked and even
though it sounds like [ __ ] to you is
that let's say you don't burn that much
calories it teaches you a habit to do
something consistently without failing
cuz that's the problem that most people
have you guys try something
you listen to these stupid [ __ ] ads
talking about you lose weight in about
two months you'll be jack then you'll be
ripped and it doesn't happen and you get
disappointed in yourself when really you
shouldn't be disappointing yourself you
should be disappointing the fact that
you actually [ __ ] believe that
[ __ ] you dumb [ __ ] you know okay
let's not call you dumb [ __ ] yeah
because I'm talking to myself right now
that I believed in that [ __ ] right and
instead of you know we listen to these
ads we listen to these [ __ ]
roided-out [ __ ] talking about
do my program and you'll be buff in
three months right [ __ ] you it's not
gonna happen cuz you're not talking
about the steroids that you're on you're
not I know people in the powerlifting
industry I know a lot of fitness gurus I
know all this other stuff and they tell
me all this stuff and I see it now I
sigh I know for a fact I know the signs
when somebody does steroids like there's
like these huge Instagram people huge
YouTube people who claim who claim that
they're not they're completely natty
and they're [ __ ] not that's why I love
like you know you know Bart was working
on this program called Kaizen that's why
I like their program a lot their stuff
was about strength numbers and if you
wanted to be fit they gave you a right
timeline to figure it out and on top of
that too they understand about nutrition
they're not guaranteeing that you'll get
a 6-pack within two three months
that's what Kaizen was really dumb
that's why I really appreciated what
they were putting out a part of Kaizen
there's there's silent mic in this guy
named Omar you saw Maurice off is a very
very intelligent um I want to I don't
want to call him a fitness guru but in
the fitness room he knows what he's
[ __ ] talking about he doesn't set
people up for failure he gives them the
right expectations his physique right
now I'm not sure right now but before he
was showing his progress and even Mike
and I saw them it takes time it didn't
take them three months to get to where
they were they set a goal and it was
like in a matter of like a year I mean
I'm gonna do it man it takes a long time
man I lost my first month I think I lost
like maybe three or four pounds maybe
I'm not even sure I don't know what it
was but around month two ish a month
three ish I'm dropped like ten or
fifteen out of nowhere nothing really
changed but something happened maybe my
body was like oh this [ __ ]
trying to lose weight I didn't know that
you know I thought yes it was like okay
well let's just drop these pounds this
guy in there and he's like okay let's
see what I'm gonna do here
[Laughter]
[Music]
so he don't know too much okay the cat
must know he walking a lot I think we do
build a muscle please give him a little
muscle because if you get too much
muscle it won't look like the rest of
your body the body just works out that
way yeah yeah I don't know I mean we
were supposed to talk about something
else but I think but that was about
health and well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast I
hope you guys enjoyed that if you're
watching this on you to leave in the
comments below I'd like to know about
your struggles with weight loss what you
think about you know Adele going through
her personal [ __ ] this is interactive
this podcast we want to hear your
opinion this is not just me talking
let's get to talk and leave it in the
comments below on youtube or if you're
on any other audio platform and they
allow you to write stuff write those
comments iTunes give us that five star
and share this podcast with your friends
because we the best podcasts out there
and we're here to keep you company homie
I think David done with the pocket can
you play with the the turn off the
button please Yakko follow me on
instagram my name Khalif boyd and uh
twitter cuz I got these Twitter fingers
and I'd be like between some really dope
[ __ ] so he's one of those dumb [ __ ]
that I follow